LACY CARUTHERS: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Women Techmakers
Give Back series,
episode two.
Today we're excited to have
Jennifer Pahlka here with us
in studio, the founder
and executive
director of Code for America.
And before we turn it over to
Jen, let me quickly introduce
myself and my host, Chris.
I'm Lacy Caruthers.
I'm on the Google Giving team.
And our focus is on identifying
and supporting
innovative nonprofits that
are using technology
to change the world.
And I've been at Google for
about six years, working
across a variety of our energy
and sustainability, as well as
our giving efforts.
And I'm joined today by Chris
DiBona, my co-host.
CHRIS DIBONA: Hi, I'm Chris.
I look after open source for the
company, and I've helped
out the Giving Team
now and then over
last couple of years.
I started at Google in 2004,
which I guess we're telling
people, and I'm just
happy to be here.
I've known Jen since Gov
2.0, but we'll talk
about that, I'm sure.
LACY CARUTHERS: Great, so now
we'll turn it over to Jen to
introduce yourself.
JEN PAHLKA: I'm so glad to be
here, thank you guys so much.
I always love coming
down to Google.
I've been looking forward
to this all week.
So I founded this organization
called Code for America.
And we call ourselves a
Peace Corps for geeks.
I have a background, as Chris
alluded to, in tech media.
And it was through this Gov 2.0
work, where I originally
met Chris, that I became
inspired by the notion that
geeks can really do something to
fix our country right now.
There's a really high need
for it, and we're at this
interesting moment where there's
a real opportunity to
do something.
A lot of conditions
that have been
holding us back are changing.
And so I created
this program--
well, we actually do a number
of things now-- but the main
thing that we do is a
servicier program.
And so we get very talented
developers and designers--
in fact one in our just
past year is from
Google, Michelle Lee--
to take a year off.
And what they do is they work
very closely with city
governments around
the country.
And they're building apps,
they're showing them lean
startup processes, they're
showing them modern tools, but
what they're really doing is
solving problems for cities
and showing how things can be
done, showing what's possible
with modern technology.
And all sorts of amazing things
happen when you really
deeply engage with people who
are living in a little bit of
a different technological
world right now.
Giving them the exposure to how
a startup would solve a
problem, how the tech industry
would solve a problem, and
letting them understand that
they can do that themselves.
So we have just had a fantastic
time in our first
couple of years trying out this
model and seeing what
happens when you put geeks
together with government.
LACY CARUTHERS: So tell us about
some of the projects
that your fellows
have worked on.
JEN PAHLKA: So this
year we actually
worked with eight cities.
It's our second year,
I should say.
We started out at our first
year, 2011, we worked with
three cities and pretty quickly
scaled up to eight.
I'll talk about one example--
and I think we can pull it up
there, if you want to go to
the Blight Status app.
We were asked to come
to New Orleans.
We sent a team of four
fellows there.
And the problem there, which is
not surprising to a lot of
people, that they wanted us
to work on is blight.
Blight's actually a problem
around the country.
It's not just Hurricane
Katrina.
That's what most people
think of.
But as our populations change in
cities where there had been
manufacturing and people have
left, you have a real issue.
It affects the economic
development.
It affects the quality of life
for people in neighborhoods.
So the mayor of New Orleans had
asked the CIO there, why
can't I just pull up on my
laptop, or my device when I'm
walking around the city, what's
going on with these
properties that are obviously
blighted?
We don't know if they've been
inspected, if they've been
reported, if there's
been a hearing.
And there wasn't a way to get
that data available to people.
Now, there are huge numbers
of people in
New Orleans who spend--
really, you would be shocked--
enormous amounts of time
tracking these things, and
going after City Hall and
saying, what's going on here?
But there was no unified
view of the data
around these things.
And so the CIO said to the
mayor, well, it's going to
take us three years and probably
millions of dollars
to upgrade all of our systems in
order to be able to have a
view of that data.
CHRIS DIBONA: Or tens of
millions of dollars.
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, he
didn't say number.
But if you're talking about
three years of government
development, it's pretty
expensive.
It tends to be a lot
more expensive
in the public sector.
So we had this wonderful woman,
Denise Ross, who said,
you know what, let's see if the
Code for America Fellows
can do something about this.
So they applied to the program
the previous year, and we sent
fellows down there this
recent February.
They did about 100 interviews
in one month down there, and
not just people in City Hall.
They're talking to these
activists in the
neighborhoods, they're talking
to librarians,
they're talking to cops.
They really get an amazing view
from all perspectives of
the problem.
They came back to San Francisco,
and in six weeks
they had an early version of
what you're seeing here, this
Blight Status.
They got all the data.
It wasn't that hard for them.
The hardest part was actually
getting the data.
They unified it.
You can now type in any address
in New Orleans, and
you get back whether it's been
reported, inspected, if
there's been a hearing, if it's
scheduled for demolition,
and if so, when.
And that doesn't seem like the
most difficult project in the
world, but convincing the people
in City Hall to give
you the data is difficult.
Normalizing all this data
that's in ridiculously
different formats.
Some of them were spreadsheets,
some of them are
ledgers, some of them were
government databases that they
had been using.
But it was a lot of work that's
not all technical work,
but the impact was enormous.
When they rolled this out in
New Orleans, they told the
fellows, you have fundamentally
changed the
conversation in New
Orleans right now.
We've gone from this defensive
City Hall and angry citizens
to two groups that are now
working together towards a
common goal.
And it's just been amazing.
And the CIO was very happy.
He stood up onstage at our
summit, and he said, I'm so
glad I was wrong about this.
Yes, they still need to upgrade
their systems, but
that's not an excuse not to
provide accurate data to
citizens, and to provide it.
And I think what's unique about
this when you look at
these interfaces is that most
government software doesn't
have interfaces like this.
So we call these interfaces to
government that are simple,
beautiful, and easy to use.
And that's part of a message,
not just to the developer
community and the government
community, but to citizens.
You should expect to have
interfaces to government that
are simple, beautiful,
and easy to use.
And society really fundamentally
changes we have
those interfaces.
CHRIS DIBONA: I think you might
have mentioned this at
the summit, but was this made
generalizable for another
city, like say, a Detroit,
Or pick another
blight-stricken city?
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, this one in
particular is a little bit
hard to generalize, because
every city has their own mess
of data on the back end.
But all the apps that the
fellows built are open source,
so some of them you can just
pretty easily re-implement.
And maybe we could talk about
Adopt-a-Hydrant, which is an
example of that.
Others will require a fair
amount to work on the part of
the city to reuse it.
But everything is built with the
intention that we're not
going to solve a problem only
one city has, because we want
to see cities adopt a really new
model, where they're not
just going to vendors and
saying, build this at high
cost to taxpayers.
But how can we shop from each
other's closets, how can we
use the solutions that have
been already implemented?
And in fact, the New Orleans
team, I'm so
proud of these guys.
They are one of the three teams
that coming out of this
year, at the end of 2012,
who are going through an
incubator with us.
They are taking this-- they
already have a contract with
the city of New Orleans to
continue working on it.
They've got other cities
interested, so they're taking
it and making it, really
a commercial product.
And they just didn't want to
stop doing what they were
doing, so they're going to
get paid to do it now.
CHRIS DIBONA: That's great.
LACY CARUTHERS: Yeah,
that's great.
So you spent a great majority
of your career in the games
industry, and then later
running Web 2.0.
So tell us about how your career
evolved, and how you
ended up launching Code
for America, and what
sparked that change?
CHRIS DIBONA: How did you
come to be you, Jen?
JEN PAHLKA: Extremely
accidentally.
I have the craziest career path,
because I came into San
Francisco after college to
work in nonprofits, and I
hated them.
And now I run one,
so go figure.
Yeah I took a job working,
actually first, initially on a
software development conference
back in 1994, with
really no technical
understanding at all.
I had no idea what anybody was
talking about for the first
several months on the job.
And I had been traveling
around Southeast Asia.
I needed a job, and
they hired me.
It was like no interest
in the subject.
But I had gone from this
top-down structure in the
nonprofit, which not so much
fun, to landing very
accidentally in first the
software development world,
which was more interesting,
and then the world of game
developers, circa 1995.
And as much as I was lost, I was
finally so happy, because
it was this crazy, creative,
incredibly smart community of
people who were doing things
that people really didn't
largely understand them, or the
general populace didn't
understand, soft of right before
games broke out to be
really mainstream.
And I think that what ties that
to what I'm doing now is
it was such a transformative
time for me to understand what
the technology world was.
I had been an American Studies
major in college, and
technology was something I felt
like I didn't understand.
And it was really the people,
and the creativity, and the
magic of development that just
completely enraptured me.
I had an amazing time.
That conference was very small
when we started it, and when I
left it was, I think,
12,000 people.
But it really just gave
me a love for what
developers can do.
And that carried on.
Then I left that.
After I had my kid I came back
and was working on Web 2.0,
and it was the same thing.
2005, Web 2.0 was just
when all of this
amazing stuff was happening.
And you really felt like you
were at the center of
something that was being
created, that was
transforming the world.
And that really led into,
I think, this
notion that the talent--
not just the talent, but
I think the spirit--
of those communities had a lot
to offer this system that we
all rely on, called
government.
Which just needs--
government has many amazing,
wonderful people
as you know, Chris.
But it's just stuck in a lot of
old ways, and it needs to
be a creative force, not
just a stagnant,
bureaucratic force.
So I think that really
informed this
idea of Code for America.
CHRIS DIBONA: One of the really
refreshing things I
found about Code for America is,
you didn't go into cities
and governments and say,
you're all broken.
You didn't go in and, we're
going to fix it.
You were like, hey,
how can we help?
What would be something that
would be really useful?
And I think your first
year was kind of
figuring out that process.
Would you like to talk
more about that?
Because I know it was a really
tricky time for you guys.
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah it
was great, though.
It was in some ways
the best year.
Definitely one thing we found
is that I think we were so
lucky to get that particular
class of fellows that year.
There was just something
about them.
And you had to be pretty brave
to do the program.
We had no track record.
It was not clear that we would
be able to pay people.
CHRIS DIBONA: Because our
donation income until after
that first year, right?
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah,
that's right.
I was very month-to-month.
And the first month, we started
with three cities,
Boston, DC--
oh, sorry, four.
So it was Boston, Philadelphia,
and Seattle, but
originally there was a fourth.
We had a fourth team that was
deployed to Washington, DC.
And what happened is, we got
our signed contract there
right before Fenty lost
the election, and
Mayor Gray came in.
And we were talking to
the new people--
actually, it was the
old people who
hadn't been fired yet.
And they said, no,
no, it's fine.
Send the fellows, send
the fellows.
It will be fine.
The fellows show up on the
first day of work in DC.
They get their badges, and they
get assigned seats, and
they're getting walked around
the office in the way that
people do on their first day.
And they are about to go to
lunch, and the general counsel
comes over with security,
and they escort
them from the building.
CHRIS DIBONA: Welcome to DC.
JEN PAHLKA: We had a reasonable
idea that this
might happen, just
from the signals.
So, actually, they went to
Clay Johnson's place.
I said, don't worry, I've
got a place for you.
Actually they called in for
their first check-in meeting
with me, and it was very
clear they were not
calling from an office.
I said, where are you?
They're like, we're in the
National Portrait Gallery.
It was cold out on the street.
So lots of chaos the first year,
but to actually answer
your question--
CHRIS DIBONA: What ever
happened to that team?
I've got to figure that out.
JEN PAHLKA: They worked on the
Civic Commons Project, which
we now call the CFA Commons,
which is really a way that you
can see a lot of these civic
technology projects, see where
they're in use, and be able to
get a sense of what's working
where in terms of mostly
open source civic tech.
But to get back to the thing,
those fellows were amazingly
emotionally intelligent, and
they were humble, and they
were curious, and
they were kind.
And so I think when people heard
about the idea-- and we
had this video that we used to
promote Code for America the
very first year that had Mark
Zuckerberg, and Caterina Fake,
and Biz Stone in it.
And I think people thought we
were going to be like, hi,
we're here from the cool part
of the internet, and we're
going to fix you.
CHRIS DIBONA: We're going
to make you cool too.
JEN PAHLKA: We're going
to make you cool
too, because we know--
CHRIS DIBONA: --we're going
to sprinkle cool on you.
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, we
know how it's done.
And the fellowship--
CHRIS DIBONA: --boring,
old government people.
JEN PAHLKA: --They were so nice,
and they were disarming.
And I think--
not [? to slag ?] on
consultants, but I think in
government, they're so used to
having McKinsey and other
consulting companies come
in, and be like,
OK, we've got a process.
We know what we're going on.
And these guys came in, they
were like, hi, we're so
excited to be here.
Could I help you do anything?
And it set the tone of a real
collaboration from the
beginning, so thank God.
LACY CARUTHERS: So for those
folks that are tuning into
this and are interested in being
a fellow at Code for
America, what types of folks
are you looking for?
JEN PAHLKA: That's
a great question.
So the name is Code for America,
but really about 2/3
of our fellows code, somewhere
between 1/2 and 2/3.
We're also looking for great
designers, graphic designers,
user experience designers.
CHRIS DIBONA: Your women
participation for the fellows
was actually pretty amazing last
year, when [INAUDIBLE].
JEN PAHLKA: Last year, we had 26
fellows overall, and 12 of
them were women, so just one
shy of half, which is good.
And a number of them actually
were engineers, and a number
of various flavors
of designer.
And we actually really have a
very diverse group of fellows.
So some of them have some
technical skills but their
background is city
planning or law.
And what you really have to
show is a high degree of
skill, the emotional
intelligence to do a job like
this, and passion.
We want people who really,
really care about what we're
trying to do.
And when you pay a very small
stipend for a year, and you're
supposed to live in San
Francisco, you really only get
people who are passionate
about it.
So it's a little bit of
a filtering thing.
But we'll be opening up--
our current class is 28 fellows
that they'll be
starting January 3.
But we'll start recruiting
again for 2014 soon.
And if anybody out there is
interested, we can always hook
you up with fellows who've
done the program.
They can tell you really
honestly what it was like.
And they've all been really
positive about it.
Two years in a row now,
basically every single fellow
has said, this was hard, it
wasn't everything I expected,
but I would totally
do it again.
And they grew, and they made
great friends, and they
learned something.
So we're very pleased.
LACY CARUTHERS: And so in
addition to the fellows
program, you guys also have a
civic start up accelerator.
So tell us more about
that program.
JEN PAHLKA: Yes, thanks
to google.org.
So one of the things we see is
that the fellows go into the
cities, and they're exposing
people in government to things
like cloud-based applications,
and services that cost a lot
less than what these guys are
used to paying, have much
better interfaces.
And what happens is--
and also I would say in
sort of a hacker way.
What happens is we create
a lot of demand.
Then they go look at the tool
set they currently have, and
they go, wow, why are we paying
so much for this, and
couldn't we start to buy things
in a different way?
And there is now something of
an ecosystem in the civic
space that you would
call 2.0 or--
I don't know what the
right term is there.
But there's not enough, right.
There need to be more smart
entrepreneurs, and developers,
and hackers, and designers that
say, I'm not just going
to go try to do my Facebook
killer, or whatever.
I'm going to solve a real
problem for our country, for
government, for citizens,
whatever, and offer these
kinds of services targeted
at the real needs
the government has.
So if we're going to succeed in
our mission long-term, we
have to build that ecosystem.
And we wanted to pick some
companies that were already
trying to do this.
We sent out a call for
applications, and everyone
said, there's no such thing
as a civic startup.
Who's going to apply?
Except you guys.
You were great.
We had 235 companies apply
for the accelerator.
CHRIS DIBONA: How
big were they?
JEN PAHLKA: It really varied
all over the map.
We chose seven of them, and they
were all pretty small.
But they ranged from Mind
Mixer, which already has
something like 250 city
government clients, to
Recovers.org, very early stage,
fantastic application
that's been in the media a lot,
because they were able to
respond to Hurricane Sandy.
They help communities organize
online for all the aid that's
coming in after a disaster,
and they were in very high
demand at the end of October.
So these companies are
just fantastic.
And it's a real market.
There's an enormous amount
of money in this market.
We're spending something like
$172 billion a year.
CHRIS DIBONA: You personally?
JEN PAHLKA: Yes, us together
personally.
Taxpayers are.
And for a point of comparison,
the video game business is now
about 10 to 15 billion.
So this is giant.
I'm not saying you should
go take a piece of a
$172 billion market.
I'm saying we should be cutting
that number in half.
But that's still a big business,
and it's doing
something to make your
country better.
CHRIS DIBONA: Great.
So speaking of mentorship and
the mentorship you guys
provide in your accelerator,
going to your personal
background, who have been your
role models and your heroes as
you've come on this path
as a woman in tech?
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, it's been
interesting because I'm a
woman in tech, but I'm not
really a developer.
I have--
CHRIS DIBONA: So you
hate developers?
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, I
hate developers, I
can't say that on here.
No, I feel really strongly
that we need to fix this
problem of fewer women
in the industry.
I'm not answering your
question, but
I'll get back to it.
My niece came out to spend the
summer at Code for America two
years ago, and I was like,
she'll hang out with all these
developers for the summer, and
she'll get the coding bug.
And I want that for her, because
I see the kind of life
you can have, the kind of
things that you can do.
And I think increasingly
it's about access to
power in this country.
So I really think it's
important, and I'm connected
to a lot of those efforts.
And I just want to see more
role models for women in
technology.
My role models have been
like my parents.
I'm sorry to say it.
But you know, you grow
up and you--
CHRIS DIBONA: I'm sure they're
not sorry to hear it.
JEN PAHLKA: Hi, Mom.
Hi, Dad.
My dad's a teacher and my mom's
a nurse midwife, and
they both--
I think later in life,
you realize how
they've influenced you.
They both care deeply
about those systems.
Our health care system has to
work for us to live well in
this country.
Our education system
has to work.
Both of those are
deeply broken.
And they're the kind of people
who worked way harder than
anyone expected them to work,
because they cared so much
about doing the right thing.
And I think as I've thought
about it later, this turn into
government, which seemed really
unlikely for me, had to
do with growing up in a
household of people who cared
about the public sector.
But in the tech world, I think
Sheryl Sandberg's done a lot
to forward this conversation
and to say really specific,
brave things about women
in the workplace.
And I'm just really impressed
with that.
But she's not the only one.
I think there's a lot of people
who are standing up and
saying, I'm happy to have
this honest dialogue
about women in tech.
LACY CARUTHERS: To those young
people, especially young women
that are interested in pursuing
this path, what would
your advice be to them?
JEN PAHLKA: I think that
what I would say is--
so I just sort of set up this
whole big thing about how
there need to be more women in
tech-- but the truth is, if
you're not coming in it from a
place of just really feeding
your own passions, it's
not the right thing.
I think it's, tap into what
really jazzes you about what
you're doing.
Any I think a lot
of women get--
the government technology space,
I think, can be great
for women for a lot
of reasons.
But one is that I see women
really wanting to solve a
particular problem.
It's not just tech
for tech's sake.
And that's a place where you can
do it really clearly, and
people come tell you, you've
had an impact on my life
because of this application
that you put up.
But I think it's sort of own
your own and career path, own
your own passions.
Own what you want to do in tech,
and that'll be the best
role model for others
in the end.
CHRIS DIBONA: So when you go
to a city, and you talk to
them, do you go in and say,
I'm going to do this to
Detroit, I'm going to do
this to [INAUDIBLE].
And then do you find yourself
disappointed, do you find
yourself energized?
What happens when you have
those first discussions?
Especially in the first year,
were your hopes and thoughts
just dashed upon the rocks
and then recover?
What happens?
JEN PAHLKA: We don't really
go in and tell them
what we want to to.
CHRIS DIBONA: But in the back
of your mind, you have this
idea of a digital city,
or [INAUDIBLE].
How did that hit [INAUDIBLE]?
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, I've always
had a couple applications in
my mind that I'd like to
have built, and we're
just not there yet.
I mean it's early stages in this
industry, and I would say
in this movement.
So more important than building
any one thing that
might be the thing you think
will get everybody on board
with reporting issues in your
city, or being involved with
civic life is just, again,
showing what's possible,
offering new models to
approach problems in.
So if we come in and say
we want to do this,
they don't own it.
They have to say, we're starting
to get that there
might be a different way to
solve this problem than the
way we've solved
it in the past.
Can you help us prove
that point?
And it's very responsive.
In fact, I talked about New
Orleans, where they knew
really clearly, this
is the problem.
Clearly the biggest thing
in the city, clearly an
opportunity where tech can be
a small intervention that
changes the conversation.
But we went into Honolulu.
They said, we don't care
what the fellows do.
We pushed them, what's
their area?
Can you give us schools,
what is it?
We don't care.
Have them come and spend a lot
of time talking to people, and
they can tell us what they want
to do during the year.
And we were a little nervous
about that, but the folks in
City Hall in Honolulu
were fantastic.
And they ended up doing this
amazing project that actually
just won an interaction
design award.
I think we pulled up a
screenshot of this too.
It's called Honolulu Answers.
I'll tell that story.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, do.
Interesting one.
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah.
So, by way, I love Honolulu.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, that's a
rough place to have to work.
JEN PAHLKA: It really
is, I know.
I was supposed to visit all of
the cities last February, and
I ended up visiting
just Honolulu.
CHRIS DIBONA: We won't tell
anyone [INAUDIBLE].
JEN PAHLKA: I know.
It was really great.
One thing is you think of it
as Hawaii, like beaches.
It's a real city.
It's giant.
It has traffic problems.
We're talking about a real
American city, but on a beach.
And it's beautiful.
So the fellows went to Honolulu,
and one of the
things I heard consistently from
everyone-- and I'm not
just talking about people
outside of government being
critical, but people
in government--
was that the website, not
really serving citizens.
And if you look at Honolulu.gov,
you'll see.
And it's still up there.
It's just not the information
that you want.
And what they did is they went,
and they looked at the
search logs.
And they said, when people come
to Honolulu.gov, what are
they trying to do?
And the top search result, for
instance, was driver's
license, which doesn't make
sense to those of us that live
in a state where the state
handles driver's licences.
In Honolulu, the city does--
or it's actually a
city and county.
So they type driver's license
into Honolulu.gov, and you get
back about 25 different
pages of information
about driver's licenses.
Never do you get back a page
that tells you how to get a
driver's license.
But there's a lot of
information, a lot of words.
So what they did was they ripped
off an interface that's
starting to be popular now in
government that the UK has
done and Utah.gov has done,
which is basically a big,
beautiful background screen
and a search box.
So instead of tyring to push a
bunch of information, what is
it you're trying to do?
And they created custom content
for those top 10
searches, driver's license
and the other ones.
So it's a simple, beautiful,
easy-to-use interface that
actually does what you
want it to do.
But then they had the problem
of how are they going to
create the rest of
the content.
And they held something that's
not a hackathon.
They held something called a
write-a-thon, first ever
write-a-thon.
They got 60 people
in Honolulu--
citizens, people in government,
across the board--
to come together
on a Saturday.
And they put all the next set of
questions up on the board,
and people came and took them
down and wrote clear, plain
language answers to the next
50 most commonly asked
questions in Honolulu.
And they continue to do that.
And so, basically, it's now
growing on it's own as a
replacement to Honolulu.gov that
is, frankly, just a lot
better at actually serving
citizens needs.
And we had no idea that's what
they were going to do.
And it worked out great.
CHRIS DIBONA: That's terrific.
One thing that was really
interesting to me is the first
year you had the Hydrant app,
and then you said it's
[INAUDIBLE]
migrated into a whole new kind
of app for a different city,
with I think is really
exciting.
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, that story was
amazing, and it's part of
the Honolulu story, too.
2011, our first year,
one of the fellows--
we sent all these fellows
to Boston in the
winter which was--
CHRIS DIBONA: That's
dedication.
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, and they were
mostly from California,
and didn't have warm coats,
and they also didn't have
ties, and they were
in City Hall.
There are some of the things
we learned the first year.
That also happened to be the
year of Snowpocalypse, so they
were in City Hall--
CHRIS DIBONA: Don't they have
those every year now?
JEN PAHLKA: No, there was no
snow last year, hardly any.
And there's not that much this
year either, which you'll hear
is actually a bummer for us.
We needed more snow
to test the app.
So they're in City Hall when
everybody's talking about
trying to plow the streets.
The dialogue in City Hall
becomes all about what streets
are plowed.
And what they realized is, when
you plow a street and the
snow gets pushed up to the
side, it covers the fire
hydrants so that you can't find
them or use them in the
event of an emergency.
Very little thing, but Eric
Michaels-Ober, one of the
fellows, said, well,
let's just see.
I'm going to write a very quick
little app that will let
you adopt a fire hydrant.
Because people are
on the street.
They're shoveling out
the sidewalks in
front of their houses.
Why don't they take the extra
step and shovel out the fire
hydrant, so that it's available
if their house
catches on fire?
Sort of trivial app that didn't
get used that first
year, because they took a month
to roll it out, and then
it wasn't showing anymore.
But a great concept.
And then when we had the second
set of cities, our 2012
cities, come visit us that fall
in preparation for being
in the program the next year,
our great partner, this guy,
Forest Frizzell, in the IT
department in Honolulu tells
me, oh, I was poking around in
your GitHub account, and I
found this thing called
Adopt-A-Hydrant, and I'm going
to use it in Honolulu.
And we're like, not
a lot of snow.
CHRIS DIBONA: It doesn't
snow here.
Sanddrifts after a big surf?
JEN PAHLKA: A little strange.
And he said no, I'm
re-purposing it as
Adopt-a-Siren.
And people steal the batteries
out of these tsunami
sirens on the beach.
Also big public hazard.
You need to know if there's
a tsunami coming to hit.
And so that was the
first reuse of it,
which I think was brilliant.
No one had said to him,
here's this thing; you
could use it for this.
He just got it and did it, and
now a bunch of the sirens are
adopted in Honolulu,
which is great.
But I think it's in about
eight of nine
cities right now already.
So Oakland where I live
just rolled it out as
Adopt-a-Storm-Drain.
If you think about it, why are
we spending a lot of money
having crews go around
and clear the leaves
out of storm drains?
I live a couple doors
down from the storm
drain on our block.
And if it gets stuck with
leaves, I can pull the leaves
out just as well as a
municipal worker.
So I've adopted the storm
drain on my street.
CHRIS DIBONA: Do you ever have
anyone accuse you of trying to
subvert the authority of the
government with these projects?
JEN PAHLKA: No.
Actually, no.
But I will say it's a little
weird to put your hand in a
storm drain.
I'm getting over it, but
you're like, ew.
CHRIS DIBONA: Have you ever
gone inside them and
[INAUDIBLE]?
JEN PAHLKA: No, no, they're
just like this, you can't.
CHRIS DIBONA: No the
aboveground part.
Especially rainy cities,
there's substantial
aboveground spaces.
It's fun.
JEN PAHLKA: No, I haven't.
I'll put that on
the life list.
CHRIS DIBONA: Don't do that,
just for the record.
We are not endorsing that.
JEN PAHLKA: OK, so you want
everyone else not to do it,
but you want me to do it?
CHRIS DIBONA: No, I want
no one to do it.
JEN PAHLKA: OK, I wont.
CHRIS DIBONA: But it's
interesting.
JEN PAHLKA: Anyway, so you can--
and by the way, this is
an app that's pretty easy to
stand up in other cities.
And one of the other programs
that we have is called this
brigade, which basically means
that you don't have to take a
year off and come work with us
to Code for America or do
civic apps.
You could, right now, wherever
you live, go to your city
government and say, hey, can
I stand up this thing?
Give me the locations of all the
park benches or whatever.
And I'll stand this up for
you, and then we'll get
citizens to start
lending a hand.
And just do it.
It's not that hard.
LACY CARUTHERS: Well I was just
going to ask, what have
you seen after--
I know you've just had a couple
of years of fellows,
but what have you seen
after the fellows
have left these cities?
Are they leaving some
kind of legacy?
Have you seen the programs
continue once they've gone?
JEN PAHLKA: It's a
good question.
That really is the point of
the program, is that if we
come in and do magic and
then leave, what's--
really, why?
So increasingly we're figuring
out what are those changes
that mean that there's
a long-lasting
difference in a city.
And I think there's
a bunch of signals
that things have changed.
And there's no indicator on the
wall that you can look at
that says, culture change in
government now 25% complete.
Well done.
But you can see--
like in Honolulu, Honolulu
Answers is a Rails app, so
they taught the staff Rails.
That's not something you see
that often, but there's a
bunch of developers who
actually do Rails now.
You see things like policies
being changed generally around
openness, open data,
open government.
You see people who had been
previously marginalized now
having the limelight, having
more power, getting
promotions, getting
more resources.
That's really common.
Because they go, oh,
that who was--
LACY CARUTHERS: That's
what you do, yeah.
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, that guy who
was saying all these crazy
things that we didn't
understand?
Now we understand what he or
she was saying, and we get
that this could be valuable.
And that's great, because
you really want it
to come from inside.
You want to take all that
internal, great spirit.
And people who work in
City Hall, they're
also regular people.
I mean, they have
Android phones.
They know--
CHRIS DIBONA: That's madness.
JEN PAHLKA: They
know how it is.
CHRIS DIBONA: I've
seen [INAUDIBLE].
JEN PAHLKA: Exactly.
It's not like that.
CHRIS DIBONA: I was [INAUDIBLE]
for a while, yeah.
JEN PAHLKA: You were what?
Yeah that's right,
that's right.
Even the people in government
will eventually start to say
bad things about bureaucracy.
But, really, it's
not immutable.
It really isn't.
It takes people who care
and see something
better to change it.
And we see that.
It's really, really gratifying
and exciting.
LACY CARUTHERS: So one thing--
just shifting gears a little
bit-- that my team thinks a lot
about and has seen on the
giving side is a huge
opportunity for nonprofits to
really leverage technology and
integrate it into the work
that they're doing.
And so I think you guys
are a great example.
You're not only innovating
within the government space,
but also within the
nonprofit space.
So could you just talk a
little bit about your
experience there and what you
have seen from the inside of
that sector, and if there
is an emerging
trend in that space?
JEN PAHLKA: Of the
nonprofit sector?
LACY CARUTHERS: Of the nonprofit
sector using and
taking advantage of technology
in better ways.
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, that's
a good question.
I don't know that I've seen
that much of the nonprofit
sector now.
I really spend a lot of
time in government.
And I'll tell you what I want
out of the nonprofit sector,
is fewer emails.
I think sending a bunch of
emails advocating for things
is useful, and there's a lot
of stuff that's going on.
But ultimately, technology can
do something a lot more
fundamental, a lot
more powerful.
And I think that there is a fair
amount of the nonprofit
sector that's stuck in the, we
lobby and we educate, and we
used to send enormous amounts
of direct mail, and now we
send enormous amounts
of email.
And one of the things I think
that set us apart--
and you were kind to say this
when you first looked at us--
is we write real code that does
something other than send
you an email.
And I think all nonprofits
should start looking at what
they can do and get beyond this
notion of engagement,
where engagement means
they clicked on
the link in the email.
I had one guy come to me last
year and say he wanted to do a
Code for America for nonprofits,
to try to get them
to think more innovatively
about government.
And I would say--
he didn't do it.
Someone else should.
Take it up.
It's a great opportunity.
There needs to be more
true innovation,
not like better MailChimp.
CHRIS DIBONA: We've run some
hackathons for nonprofits, and
it's always really surprising
how underdeveloped
their system is.
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, and
it's unfortunate,
because they also see--
when you talk to a lot of
nonprofits about technology,
they're coming at you with,
like, our server doesn't work.
They're really at a very
operational level around it,
and you kind of want to go, I
totally hear you, but we need
to get these basic needs met
so you can move forward.
And it's a resource issue.
We need to resource
them better.
LACY CARUTHERS: So I think
we have time for
about one more question.
Any burning questions, Chris?
Let's see, last one.
I guess maybe just concluding
with any final words you have
to share with, as a woman in
tech, given that this is the
Women Techmakers series.
Maybe some of the best advice
that you've ever gotten,
that's helped you
in your career.
JEN PAHLKA: Yeah, that's
a good question.
I think I was supposed to have
a good answer for this.
LACY CARUTHERS: Or just
final parting words.
JEN PAHLKA: I think the best
advice I would give is that
you get a lot of advice,
and it all conflicts.
And in the end--
LACY CARUTHERS: You get
asked about it a lot?
JEN PAHLKA: In the end, if you
close your ears off, you're
doing yourself a great
disservice.
But if you try to take it all,
you will become psychotic.
And I actually think that people
from outside the tech
industry often look at me as,
oh, you're a woman in tech.
Let's talk about that.
And my response to them is tech
is actually, yes, I get
that there is a real
gender divide here.
But is actually a pretty--
most parts of the tech industry
that I see are pretty
open and welcoming to women.
And I do think it's important to
talk about the places where
the industry becomes
very unfriendly.
And I don't think people get
what they're doing, and I
think a little education can
help them when they're being
very off-putting.
But I think it's also important
to talk about the
places that are incredibly
supportive.
Code for America is,
I think, a pretty
supportive place for women.
We've talked about issues
that have come up
from time to time.
But there are great
opportunities.
And I think if we frame this as
a place where you're going
to be fighting through a jungle
all the time to get any
respect, not only does
that not help us,
but you know what?
I worked in the media industry
for a long time.
I've worked in a bunch
of industries.
Sexism is not unique to
the tech industry.
Has anyone been anywhere
else lately?
So I don't think it's
particularly that
must worse in tech.
And I think there's a lot of
opportunity, and I think I
would like women to
see it as fun.
LACY CARUTHERS: Great.
Well, thank you so much for
joining us today, Jen.
That was really fascinating.
Thanks for sharing.
CHRIS DIBONA: Before you go, you
should tell us the URL and
where people can
find your code.
Because someone asked
about that.
LACY CARUTHERS: URL, yes.
We're at codeforamerica.org,
and we would love
to see you all there.
Signal your interest in being
a fellow, or in getting your
city on board with our program,
or contributing to
our annual campaign.
And then if you would like to
look at some of our code--
CHRIS DIBONA: Which is
all open source.
JEN PAHLKA: Which is all
open-- we have too many
[? repodes. ?]
That's the feedback we're
going to get.
We're going to be cleaning up
this December, which is
halfway over.
We are at
github.com/codeforamerica.
And go play.
We have some great
projects there.
We'd love to see people
get involved.
CHRIS DIBONA: Thank you
so much for your time.
LACY CARUTHERS: Thank
you so much.
And thanks to all of you for
tuning in to the second
episode in our Women Techmakers
for Good series.
We'll be here tomorrow as well,
at the same time, 2:30
Pacific Standard Time, with
Sasha Laundy of Codecademy,
CHRIS DIBONA: Whch is a terrific
site if you haven't
tried it out.
LACY CARUTHERS: So stay tuned
to learn more about women
innovating in the tech
space for good.